So church, I've been praying all week that today would be
a monumental day in the life of our church
because I've been praying that today would be transformative
in each of us individually.
'cause today what we're coming to in the narrative of
two Samuel is the mostly familiar story of David
with Bathsheba.
But really it's so much bigger than
that in many ways.
This is your story. My story.
We're gonna see so many parallels of how this works out,
where the way we handle our lives today is similar
to our failures and and even coverups and how we handle
and respond to sin in our lives.
All of that. And my prayer is
that we would walk into this today receptive.
Receptive to what God wants to do and reveal in us,
but also receptive to how he wants to heal us.
That there's freedom. Now, as I've said
before, up to this point in Second Samuel,
things have been pretty good.
All the victories and anointing is king
and all this things like that.
But today starts the slide for David
and for Israel.
God will still work going forward,
but it will be accompanied by so much trouble along the way
All as a result of this today.
So let's start in chapter 11
of two Samuel, chapter 11.
And as we look at these two chapters,
here's what I want you to look for.
Watch for the deadly progression of sin.
Watch as we go through these verses.
We'll just start with verse one, chapter 11,
In the spring of the year, the time when kings go out
to battle, David sent Joab and his servants with him
and all Israel and they ravaged the Ammonites
and besieged Reba.
But David remained at Jerusalem.
Now this is brilliant narration.
Using that war with the Ammonites as context,
the narrator mentions that this was normal for kings.
Every time the spring would come around,
if they were in a battle, they would go out to see how their
warriors were doing.
See how the battle was going.
Yet this verse immediately in just a few words,
indicated something was wrong.
It says, but David remained at Jerusalem.
The king had abdicated his responsibility.
He wasn't doing what he was supposed to do at that time.
And even further, we see,
look at the first part of verse two.
It happened late one afternoon
where David arose from his couch
and was walking on the roof of the king's house.
We'll stop there for a second.
So not only was David not at the battle like he was supposed
to be here in the middle of the afternoon, he's taken a nap.
We don't know whether it was because of pride or laziness
or selfishness, but for some reason
those things had taken over
and David had failed to lead in this moment.
It was a setup for disaster.
Watch what happens here in verse two.
It happened late one afternoon when David arose from his
couch was walking on the roof of the king's house
that he saw from the roof, a woman bathing
and the woman was very beautiful.
You see where this is headed, don't you?
Now I wanna clear something up here
before we go any further.
Before you think this woman was somehow inviting this on
herself by being on her rooftop, taking a bath.
This was what verse four says, her ritual uh,
cleansing process after her monthly cycle.
And so what that means is that this was actually her being
faithful to God in the moment,
which means she would've been doing it a very modest private
way getting above everybody else
and trying to stay outta sight and doing it very modestly.
That's what she was doing. It wasn't
what you might imagine it was.
Now David had a choice to make right here.
Yes, he was abdicating his responsibilities.
He was at not at war like he was supposed to be,
but this was still an accident that he happened to see her.
It would, it wasn't like he went on purpose out there,
he just happened to walk outside, saw her.
So it wasn't on purpose, it was an accident.
But what would he do with that?
Again, watch the deadly progression of sin
verses three through five.
And David sent and inquired about the woman.
One said is this not Bathsheba, the daughter of Eli,
the wife of Uriah, the Hittite.
And so David sent messengers and took her
and she came to him and he lay with her.
Now she'd been purifying herself from her uncleanness.
Then she returned to her house and the woman conceived
and she sent and told David, I'm pregnant
Now David has a problem on his hands
because where was Uriah?
Uriah, her husband, one of David's 30 mighty men
who were the strongest warriors,
the one they sent into all the battles at the front
that they were the ones who did all the heroic things.
He was out on the battlefield where he was supposed to be,
where David was supposed to be.
Uriah is over there.
And so this is a problem that there's no way to claim.
Uriah is the father.
So watch what David did, verses six through 13.
So David sent word to Joab, send me Uriah, the Hittite
and Job sent Uriah to David.
And when Uriah came to him, David asked how Joab was doing
and how the people were doing, how the war was going.
And David said to Uriah, go down to your house
and wash your feet.
Go relax. Basically Uriah went outta the
king's house and there followed
him, a present from the king.
But Uriah slept at the door of the king's house
with all the servants of his Lord
and did not go down to his house.
When they told David Uriah did not go down to his house,
David said to Uriah, have you not come from a journey?
Why did you not go down to your house?
Relax, enjoy a Uriah said to David,
the ark in Israel and Judah dwell in booths or tents
and my Lord Joab
and the servants of my Lord,
the the army are camping in the open field.
Shall I then go to my house to eat and to drink
and to lie with my wife as you live
and as your soul lives, I will not do this thing.
And then David said to Uriah, remain here today also
and tomorrow I'll send you back.
So Uriah remained in Jerusalem that day and the next
and David invited him and he ate in his presence
and drank so that he made him drunk.
And in the evening he went out to lie on his couch
with the servants of the Lord.
But he did not go down to his house.
This was David's effort to try to cover up the problem,
to try to get Uriah to enjoy his wife
and then be able to claim that that baby was Uriah's.
'cause remember they didn't have DNA tests back then.
It was just like it was the same kind of timeframe.
Surely that's Uriah's.
Yet did you see how honorable Uriah was in this moment?
Like he couldn't even fathom that his buddies are living and
and fighting on the battlefield and he's over here.
There's no way he could do that. It would not feel right.
He's that honorable of a man.
Quite the comparison to David in this moment.
David even tried to get him drunk to to
where he would do it just because and and he still didn't.
The deadly progression of sin continued.
Look at verses 14 through 17
in the morning, David wrote a letter to Joe Abs,
sent it by the hand of Uriah.
In the letter he wrote, set Uriah in the forefront
of the hardest fighting, then draw back from him
that he may be struck down and die.
And as Joab was Besieging the city, he assigned Uriah
to the place where he knew there were valiant men.
And the men of the city came out, fought against Joab
and some of the servants of David
among the people fell Uriah.
The Hittite also died.
So the coverup continued now even further
by putting this woman's husband to death,
essentially murdering him
by putting him in an impossible situation at the forefront
of the battle everybody else pulls back.
And so he takes all the arrows.
He had no chance, which then
led David to eventually do what he did.
Looked down at verse 26, this was after the news came back
and forth and everything happened.
And he found out in 26 when the wife of Uriah heard
that Uriah, her husband was dead,
she lamented over her husband.
And when the morning was over, David sent
and brought her to his house and she became his wife
and bore him a son.
Do you see the deadly progression
of sin in David's life?
Like just watch this. Let's track
through from the very beginning, let's go all the way back
to before anything happened.
David could have followed the lead of job who said,
I'm gonna make a covenant with my eyes not
to look upon a woman with lust.
Job 31 1. He said, I'm not gonna do it at all.
David could have said, I'm not gonna do it either.
But he looked when he should have looked away.
Now he could have cut it off right there, dealt with
that in his heart, said okay, no, I gotta fight
that lust, gotta kill it.
Okay, I gotta do that. I mean he could have repented
and walked in holiness,
but instead he began to covet
this other man's wife, which is the number 10
of the 10 commandments.
And he began to want that and
and so he could have at that point, even again, cut it off.
He could have stopped right there.
He could have dealt with it. He could have ruthlessly
dealt with the sin in his heart.
Say man, like why is that coveting in there?
I don't want that. God, I don't want that anymore.
He could have stopped right there,
but no, he instead broke then
the seventh commandment
by abusing his power over this innocent woman
and taking her to commit adultery.
And then when his manipulation of the situation and lying
and cheating and all the things to try to get all
that done didn't work.
It progressed to breaking the sixth commandment, murder.
All of those were just to try to cover up his initial sin.
The first one he was just trying
to make sure he didn't happen.
Uh, it didn't get
caught, man.
James one is so clear
on sins deadly progression.
Listen to this. But each person is tempted when he's lured
and enticed by his own desire.
And then desire when it has conceived, gives birth to sin
and sin when it is fully grown, brings forth death.
Do you not see it here?
The temptation is not the sin, it's
what you do with it in your heart.
And if you have any unaddressed weakness
and then you face an unexpected opportunity,
it can lead to disaster.
Now here's the crazy thing about this.
David at this point probably thought
it worked because this
was nine months.
Bathsheba has given birth.
Now she got pregnant at the sin time.
So nine months later, since that time, she gives birth
and she'd been David's wife ever since
that beginning point roughly nine months ago.
And so surely everybody thinks, well that's David's child.
And so you can imagine David at this point saying,
whew man, I'm safe.
Made it. I'm okay. Everything is fine.
If you hear nothing else today, if you write one thing down
and you walk away with one thing, hear this
Satan's primary lie.
His main lie is when he whispers in your heart,
Nobody's gonna find out.
He just plants that little seed in your heart,
in your mind saying nobody's gonna know.
But look at the very last phrase of verse 27 here.
But
the thing that David had done
and displeased the Lord like
so simple yet so piercing.
'cause the way it actually says it's just displease the Lord
like he had a bad meal.
It's like it, the way it says in Hebrew is
that it was evil in the Lord's sight.
What David had done was evil before God.
Listen, we gotta hear this today.
There is no such thing as hidden sin.
It every secret sin is in full
view of a holy God.
There's nothing you can text or look at
or think about that he doesn't see you do.
That's why Hebrews four 13 Demolishes,
every delusion we have about that, it says,
no creature is hidden from his sight, but all are naked
and exposed to the eyes of him to whom we must give account.
We should never think
that any sin is just not that big a deal.
Well, not doing what David did,
it's just this white little lie or whatever it is.
Like it's just not a big deal.
No, listen, God almighty sees it
and he is a god of justice.
We must not skate past that, just defaulting into mercy.
We must not take for granted the mercy of God
because of the terrible justice of God.
We've gotta respect this.
And when I say the word terrible, that means awe inspiring.
It means something that you can't help
but be afraid of a little bit, right?
That's terrible. That's what that word means.
We have to respect this.
Like even if David thought he was fine,
nine months later I'm safe.
God was not through with David's heart yet
watch God's precision.
Cutting to the heart of David chapter 12,
God sends Nathan the prophet
chapter 12 verses one through six.
And the Lord sent Nathan to David.
He came to him and said to him,
there were two men in a certain city,
the one rich and the other poor.
The rich man had very many flocks and herds,
but the poor man had nothing
but one little U lamb which he had bought.
And he brought it up and it grew up with him
and with his children it used to eat of his morsel
and drink from his cup and lie in his arms.
It was like a daughter to him.
Now there came a traveler to the rich man
and he was unwilling to take one of his own flock
or herd to prepare for the guest who'd come to him.
But he took the poor man's lamb
and prepared it for the man who had come to him.
Then David's anger was greatly kindled against the man.
And he said to Nathan, as the Lord lives,
the man who's done this deserves to die.
He shall restore the lamb fourfold.
He, because he did this thing and
because he had no pity,
like isn't that amazing?
Do you see how God confronted David by using this parable
that created an emotional response in David?
He got so angry at this rich man
who took the one lamb from the poor man
and he was so mad at that guy.
He's like, let's go kill him right now.
He said all of that, not realizing the plank in his own
eye that he had taken Bathsheba
from your eye.
That's why verse seven starts
with the sword thrust of divine truth.
Watch this, Nathan said to David, you are the man.
That's you, David, this whole parable that's about you.
You are the one who did that very thing.
And so there was no, for David hide,
his sin had been exposed.
He couldn't cover it up anymore.
He couldn't lie his way out of it anymore.
He was guilty,
which prepared the way for Nathan
to twist the knife even more.
Watch David's David received the indictment from God
verses seven through nine.
Nathan said to David, you are the man
thus says the Lord, the God of Israel.
I anointed you king over Israel.
I delivered you outta the hand of Saul.
I gave you into your master.
I gave your master's house and your master's wives
and into your arms and gave you the house
of Israel and of Judah.
And if this were too little,
I would add to you as much more.
Why have you despised the word of the Lord to do
what is evil in his sight?
You've struck down your eye.
The Hittite with the sword have taken his wife
to be your wife and have killed him with the sword
of the Ammonites.
Isn't that just crushing? Like look at what God says.
God says, David, I anointed you. I delivered you.
I gave you this house.
Why have you despised the word of the Lord
to do what is evil?
David had received grace upon grace beyond measure.
He had come from the shepherd's house to the throne
of Israel to become the most prominent king in all
of the world in many ways.
And he trampled all over that for a moment
of selfish pleasure.
Isn't that sad?
But isn't that what you and I do every single day?
Like this is the anatomy of sin that we
despise the goodness of God
and we exchange his glory for created things.
We turn our back on his goodness
and we say, no, I'm gonna do it my way.
I've got a better plan. That's the anatomy of sin.
And I can give you millions of examples.
Just give you a couple. God
has accepted us as we are.
Yet we then turn around
and use gossip to try to elevate ourselves
above other people, exchanging the glory
of God for created things.
Self-promotion.
God has blessed you.
Married couples with sexual fulfillment in marriage
and you're addicted to pornography.
Exchange the glory of God for created things.
He's entrusted money to us to meet our needs
and to play a part in the kingdom of God advancing.
That's why he gave us the money he gave us.
Yet we turn around and instead buy more toys
and more experiences for ourselves.
Glory of God for created things.
God is the author of life.
Yet we try to take control of that with a missed period pill
because we don't wanna deal with the shame
that will come from an unexpected pregnancy.
Glory of God created
things and on and on and on.
We could go. You are the
man, you are the woman.
I am the man in the parable.
You are the person in the parable.
Stop pointing fingers at everybody else.
Their sins worse than mine. No, no.
All of us, all of us are guilty before God.
And listen, if you are not a follower of Christ, all
of those things and all the other things
will send you to hell.
One Corinthians six. You will
not inherit the kingdom of God.
But even if you are a follower of Christ, we
so quickly gloss over, whitewash over the consequences
of sin in our lives from all of those sins that we
exchange the glory of God for
we are forgiven, but pain still comes
when we sin against God.
That's what we see next. In verses 10 through 12,
God says, now therefore the sword shall never depart from
your house, David, because you've despised me
and have taken the wife of your eye, the Hittite
to be your wife, thus says the Lord, behold,
I will raise up evil against you out of your own house.
And I will take your wife
before your eyes, give them to your neighbor.
He shall lie with your wives in the sight of this son
for you did it secretly.
But I will do this thing before all Israel and
before the Son even verse 14,
because by this deed you have utterly scorned the Lord.
The child who is born to you shall die.
That was the child that Bathsheba confe conceived.
Nine months later, all of
that God says, that child's gonna die.
These are the consequences for David's sin.
David, one person, all of those wreckages
around him was because of his sin.
He'd be forgiven. Absolutely. We'll get to that later.
But the consequences of sin would follow him to his grave.
The sword would never depart from his house.
What that means is he would always have
strife and rebellion.
Even more of his sons would die by their own swords.
All of that would happen because of his sin.
I say all that Christian to remind us
that God's forgiveness is free.
God's forgiveness is full,
but the consequences
of sin in this fallen world will remain.
Galatians six, you reap what you sow.
God designed the world in a certain way.
It happens as a result of that.
We cannot play with fire and expect not to be burned.
And even when their fire is put out, the scars
of the burn still remain.
That's why quick repentance is so critical,
even in the life of the believer.
It's not just to get into heaven, it's repentance day
after day after day after day because we need it
and we need to stay close to the Lord in fellowship.
And so that's what we wanna give you some space
for here in the next few minutes should be daily.
But just for a moment,
because every one of us has something we need to come
before the Lord and say, God, I am wrong in this.
I need to confess this.
By the way, confession is not saying
to God something he doesn't already know.
You're agreeing with God that that is sin.
And you say, God, this is what I've done.
This is my sin in my life.
I need you to remove it from my life.
I need you to change my heart. That's confession.
And so this is a time to open your life, to open your heart,
to break through whatever wall that you've built
between you and God.
He didn't go anywhere. You walked away
and built a wall up there by your own sin.
How do you get past that? And you break through.
That starts with confession. It starts with owning it.
Now we're not through with the story yet,
so I'm gonna come back here in a little bit
and we'll finish that so you don't need to leave, but,
but let's just sit in this for a while
and we're gonna sing a song and,
and it will maybe give you some words,
but I, I don't, I don't want us
to move past that.
The weight of sin too quickly.
We, we need, we need to feel it a little bit or else grace
and mercy isn't as great as we might say it is
or think it is because we need to sit in this.
So, so as as we sing this song together, this is not,
maybe you just need to pray the words your head bowed,
I'd clo just like processing.
God, show me where I'm wrong.
Show me any wicked way within me.
Lead me like I need you, God.
And and agree with them in that even you get on your face
before I'm right now or on your knees just, just
to reflect head down and and say, God, where am I?
What's between us? And confess it
and I'll come back in a little bit, but let's just rest.
Sit in this for a while. In this moment
You see,
you hear my voice, you hear his life,
you hear
my love.
You know my
Heart.
You know my Heart.
Deep inside, you know My,
my love.
Fix my Soul upon
My heart.
Burn it down to to
Christ.
My glory
of my
Heart,
my Christ, my
into my.
Now here's the question that comes up at this point.
How could God forgive David for all that he'd done?
Intentional sins like assault, adultery,
murder, manipulation.
Like if we take this literally, if we take this to the place
where the law would say we should go, he deserved death.
The letter of the law said you deserve death.
And so how could Nathan say in verse 13,
the Lord has put away your sin, you shall not die.
Like how's it even possible for David?
How's that fair guide?
Just a couple chapters to go touch the ark and die?
Like how is this for David?
The reality is that mercy is never
Fair.
Mercy's never fair. And what we discover is
that God forgave David in anticipation
of the greater sacrifice that was to come.
'cause Hebrews 10 talks about even if David would've done
all the sacrifices of bulls and goats
and all those things, it still wouldn't have been enough.
There still needed to be a perfect sacrifice.
Those could never take away sins.
But the perfect sacrifice, Jesus Christ actually can
because he was the one who faced every temptation that you
and I faced yet never gave in, never sin.
He's also the one who's finished work accomplished all
that we need to bring about our salvation.
Now, I know David lived a thousand years before Jesus came
and did what he did, but David was still looking to Yahweh
as the only one who could cover his sin.
The only one who could actually take care of by faith,
take care of David's sin.
'cause look at what David said here. Verse 13.
His sin was exposed, his heart was convicted.
Watch what David says to Nathan,
I have sinned against the Lord.
Simple. I've sinned against the Lord.
Remember the previous king, Saul deflected blamed.
He never took ownership of his sin.
David understood what he'd done.
He said, no, I sinned against the Lord.
I've sinned against others. I've heard other people.
I understand that. But God is the ultimate authority.
That's who our sin is against primarily.
I love what Jerry Bridges said.
Failure to see our sin as primarily against God
is the reason we experienced
so little heartfelt grief over it.
David saw that David repented.
In fact, we see a record of
that experience over in Psalm 51.
So I wanna invite you to turn there.
David wrote this psalm in response to
what we just saw in Second Samuel Psalm 51.
I'm gonna read most of it because
'cause now with the context, like you can read Psalm 51
every day, any day, but now feel
what David would've been feeling in the moment as he's going
through what he's going through in Psalm 50
and in two Samuel 11 and 12, what's he feeling?
How is he respond? Here it is.
Psalm 51,
have mercy on me.
Oh God, according to your steadfast love.
That's that hesed covenant kindness we saw last week
according to your abundant mercy.
Blot out my transgressions,
wash me thoroughly from my iniquity.
Cleanse me from my sin. For I know my transgressions.
My sin is ever before me against you.
You only have I sinned
and done what is evil in your sight so
that you may be justified in your words,
blameless in your judgment.
Behold, I was brought forth in iniquity and sined.
My mother conceived me.
Behold, you delight in truth in the inward being you teach
me wisdom in the secret heart.
Purge me with his up. I shall be clean. Wash me.
I shall be wider than snow. Let me hear joy and gladness.
Let the bones you've broken rejoice.
Hide your face from my sins. Blot out all my iniquities.
Create in me a clean heart.
Oh God, renew a right spirit within me.
Cast me not away from your presence.
Take not your holy Spirit from me.
Restore to me the joy of your salvation.
Uphold me with a willing spirit.
Then I will teach transgressors your ways
sinners will return to you.
Deliver me from blood guiltiness, oh God,
oh God, of my salvation.
My tongue will sing out of your righteousness.
Oh Lord, open my lips, my mouth will declare your praise
for you will not delight and sacrifice or I would give it.
You will not be pleased with a burn offering.
The sacrifices of God are a broken spirit, a broken
and contrite heart.
Oh God, you will not despise like you.
See this. David turned
to the Lord for mercy.
He knew that God was the only one who was the source
of steadfast love, never ending kindness.
I need that. He's crying out for a ing
his sin he knew had made him spiritually dirty.
He had broken his fellowship with God.
And so he's like, God, I need you to wash me clean
and bring me back into your presence.
That's what verse seven was referring
to when he talked about the hisp.
That was a plant that all over the Old Testament was both a
symbol and a tool of God's cleansing over people.
They would use it to brush the blood over the
doorposts at Passover.
They would use it to, to cleanse lepers, all that.
It was like he knew I need internal cleansing.
God, I'm dirty. I'm wicked.
I need you to wash me clean, to cry for mercy.
And gratefully, God showed David mercy, right?
He didn't give him what he deserved.
But I want you to think about this from our perspective.
David had what he had at the time and he cried for mercy.
We today have so much more understanding than David had.
He was placing his faith in a promise.
He was looking forward to a savior redeemer to come
and he knew it was gonna happen.
Genesis three said it would and it was going to happen.
But we now know looking back, that's Jesus
who is our great high priest who did everything needed
for us to be saved.
That's what one John two says.
My little children, I'm writing these things to you
so you may not sin,
but if anyone does sin, we have an advocate
with the Father Jesus Christ, the righteous.
He is the propitiation for our sins, not for ours only,
but for the sins of the whole world.
That's who Jesus is.
Our great redeemer who paid the price
for us that we deserved, he took it and it counts.
And so that is why even more than David could,
we today can exalt the immeasurable mercy of our God.
Like we, we do need to understand the justice
of God, but the more we understand the holiness
and justice of God, the more it exalts his mercy to us,
his grace to us, that he doesn't give us what we deserve.
He gives us all these gifts, including salvation.
We need to exalt that.
Appreciate that respect, that honor that celebrate that
because hear me, what that means is
that if God could forgive David,
he could forgive you for all that David did.
If he could forgive David, he can forgive you.
If God could still include David
and Bathsheba in the lineage of the Messiah,
he can take the ashes of your life
and make something beautiful out of it.
How do you do that? How do you get that
as you run to the cross?
That's how it happens. One John one, nine,
if we confess our sins, he's faithful
and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all unrighteousness, you go to God
and say, God, I agree with you.
That is sin. I need you
to cleanse me from my unrighteousness.
And here's what God does.
He applies the blood of Christ to wash you clean.
Like Isaiah one 18 says,
come let us reason together, says the Lord.
Though your sins are like scarlet,
they shall be white as snow.
Though they're red like crimson,
they shall be become like wool.
That's how God saves you in the first place
that you are a sinner, separated from God,
enemy of God dirty.
He cleanses you, brings you into the family.
But that's also how you keep fellowship with God.
Day after day after day, you sin, you repent.
He washes you clean, renews a right spirit within you.
You sin. He cleans you.
As you repent, washes you, gives you a right spirit,
renews a clean all He.
It's back and forth. It's what happens day
after day after day.
I know some of you walked in here today
not feeling the joy of the Lord.
You're not feeling the joy of your salvation.
We're talking about it and singing about it
and you're just like, well, it's kind of whatever.
It's not this way every time, but it might be
because you are harboring sin in your heart
and you're not confessing it.
And and David talks about it, eating up your bones
as you don't confess, you hold it in.
Like maybe you're just kind of apathetic about God.
You're just like, whatever, I don't care. Kinda bored.
It might be that you've got
that closet in your heart stuffed full of junk
and you need to clean it out.
David wrote later in Psalm 32, how blessed it is
to be forgiven, to feel forgiven, to know
that you're washed clean before God.
That is the greatest blessing.
To have your sin covered, to have your, your sin covered
and counted as nothing.
That your spirit is no deceit.
Confession is the key to unlock that.
Like you want that right? You wanna feel free before God.
That's how you get there. Confession and repentance
and restoring, receiving the blood of Christ
to wash you.
Clean and hear me.
It is a whole lot better to confess than it is to get caught
to initiate and say, here's what I've been doing than
to get caught and say, here's what you've been doing.
Whole different response to those things.
And so what wall does God want
to break down in your heart today?
How does he want to clean out the junk
that you've just caught up?
Let sit in there right now. How does he wanna do that today?
And as we've been walking through this, it might feel
to you that you're just shattered.
Like you know what's in there, nobody else knows,
but you know what's in there and you're just kinda wrecked,
crushed over that.
Listen to this. Remember Psalm 51, verse 17.
The sacrifices of God are a broken spirit,
a broken contrite heart.
Oh God, you will not despise.
That's fine if you feel broken.
That's how he wants you to come to him.
He doesn't care about the sacrifices of money and
and singing and praying, like that's not the biggest thing.
What he wants is your heart broken
before him to say, I need you, God.
I can't clean myself. I can't fix myself. I need you.
He says, come to me
All who are weary and burdened and I'll give you rest.
Listen, sin is far more dangerous
Than you may think.
And God's justice Is
Far more real Than you may think.
But God's mercy is far more glorious
Than you might think And succumb
to the altar of Christ.
Just come to the cleansing flood of Jesus,
blood washing you clean.
He shed it for you, and it washes over you
and it makes you clean.
It removes your sins. As far as the east is from the West.
That's as far as you can go.
It's impossible to get there from the other side.
It's as if it's impossible to come back from.
That's what he does when you come to him
with a broken heart, humble spirit saying, God, I need you.
I can't do it myself. I need you all that you did
to count for me.
And so for the rest of our time today,
this area up here is open.
This is not the altar we're telling you to come to.
We're telling you to come to the altar of Christ,
but there's something symbolic that it might be.
I need to go kneel. I need
to get a couple of friends with me.
And we need to confess and talk and pray together
and just say, God, I'm all in
to lay it all down before the Lord, by yourself with a few.
And listen, if there's something burdening your heart
so much, we're gonna have prayer partners at the corners.
So you can just come forward to the end
and go over to the edge and
there'll be people there to pray with
you. If you need that,
If Or just there at your seat, you run to the altar
of Christ, maybe get on your knees there or whatever it is.
You just want his forgiveness.
'cause you know you're a sinner in need of it.
That's what this is for today.
And so, God, I pray You continue
to stir our hearts towards you in this.
Lead us in the way everlasting. Show us where we are again.
So far from your standard.
We fall short of the glory of God
and the wages of sin is death,
but the gift of God is eternal life
through Jesus Christ our Lord.
So give us faith to come to you today.
Whatever that looks like, however we respond in that, Lord,
just lead us out of the darkness into the light.
Help us today. In Jesus' name, amen. Amen.
If you're able to stand together and respond.